you seem like you got an old school name
what's your name
deb
and it's just deb too it's not even
short for anything
it's deb
she calls this her snatch
[Applause]
[Laughter]
howard come in here and eat this snatch
[Applause]
he's just like all right i'm coming deb
[Laughter]
do you guys still role play that'll be
great
this is real slow he's like the cop he's
like i'm coming in to get you swear to
god
i can't bang the door down you got to
unlock the bathroom door i can't
put your foot into it
hey i hope i'm out you know
38 years i'll be dead in 38 years but
i'm starting late that's the whole
beauty of it
when my chick starts to spoil i'll be
dead
[Laughter]
jokes it's just a joke it's just a
[ __ ] joke you feminist [ __ ] i see
your face
i see your i see your socks i know what
you're about
she's just furious with me like oh this
guy hates the woman
you need a man in your life goddammit
i'm sorry sir
[Music]
he's like he's got to look on his face
like tell i've been trying to tell him
forever
i like it you you know how i know he
agrees with me because he's going like
this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah that car ride home is going to be
like oh so you [ __ ] you know
[Laughter]
you're going to go home with deb is that
what you're going to
do like at least i'll get some snatch
around here
[Applause]
you know i'm just teasing you right
are we good is he gonna come and keep my
wife's name out your [ __ ] mouth
is that what you're gonna do
[Laughter]